[Musik]
presse es ist ein wunderschöner tag
freunde mich würd sagen wir schauen
jetzt mal was film dort macht los geht
es ist gerade genau 11 uhr und wir
werden gleich nach maastricht fahren
richtig luca warum party nach maastricht
wobei mir studieren ein paar freundinnen
maß nicht aber die sind alle nicht da
aber wir fahren da auf jeden fall hin
weil ich immer noch von porsche den 911
zur verfügung gestellt bekommen habe und
davor schon jetzt und da natürlich auch
den sprit bezahlt haben wir uns gedacht
war das doch mal auslegen würde ich
sagen sehen uns jetzt im auto wieder
dazu bock auf maastricht herr wand sehr
gut
wir fahren am estrich der fall
maastricht das ist eigentlich ganz
geiles wetter und wir könnten eigentlich
gefahren aber ich muss mein block
schneiden gartenstadt
wir sind vorangekommen maastricht ich
habe jetzt die ganze zeit auf der fahrt
in die geschnitten bin aber noch bis zur
minute vier gekommen weil wir halt
wirklich bis hierhin irgendwie 40
minuten gefahren sind
erfahrung wieder kleine pieks da nimmt
keine unserer ic und master karten haben
wir müssen jetzt extra zur dominos
laufen nämlich peter geld umtauschen
können wichtig endlich alter hast du
noch etwas zu essen
es ist halt wirklich gerade einfach 15
uhr und wir haben noch gar nichts
gegessen
die innenstadt hier ist toll aber wir
wollen eigentlich nur das essen im
restaurant und in der karte steht
einfach bei dem engelberger gedrucktes
in kaarst habe ich das ja gerade google
übersetzer eingegeben und das heißt wir
selbst geräucherte steckdosen und
kirchen was letztlich davon dass unsere
bürger zu 90 euro so besteht
dafür hat fritz burger
[Musik]
ja
und ich wollte etwas sagen als bei milan
zu spielen haben jetzt auf jeden fall
aufgegessen sind nur kurz durch die
innenstadt gelaufen und jetzt fahren wir
tatsächlich einfach wieder zurück köln
und wir sind mal wieder tanzen unsere
lieblichen die letzten tag
wir sollten einfach um 17 uhr 55 zu
hause das ist gerade 18 40 und bestimmt
im stau der kölner verkehr faktor war so
hart
wir sind jetzt in einer wohnung
angekommen bin und ich und werden jetzt
eben unsere sachen packen damit ich
finde die junge du bist echt stressig
werden jetzt auf jeden fall zum
flughafen bringen weil der ja jetzt
zurück nach mallorca fliegen wird und
ich wir sitzen wieder im baby
logistische in diesem jahr auf den weg
zum flughafen filmer kurz die
kontersituationen hier auf jeden fall
gut dem platz genutzt
[Applaus]
endlich weg geil
halt
[Musik]
ja es war gerade mal ein fortschritt bei
fällen von allen walker ja ich lerne
immer noch dieses lied wir fragen wie
was davon meinen künsten hält findest du
ich kann das lied schon einigermaßen
okay danke und ich putze jetzt erst mal
die zähne an dieser stelle würde ich den
heutigen blog allerdings auch beenden
heute ist wie eine menge passiert wir
waren heute morgen in köln
zwischenzeitlich dann in den
niederlanden in maastricht dann wieder
in kölner flughafen ist bin ich habe
meine eltern in bielefeld ich bin
ehrlich gesagt schon ganz schön hart
sind
ich habe die letzten nicht immer nur so
45 stunden gepennt und deswegen habe ich
diesen 18 stunden geplant und jetzt ist
mir gerade aufgefallen dass ich in zehn
minuten nach seminar weise herr die wir
sofort wieder
ich bin mit abstand der jüngste mensch
der sagt mir halt nur meinen kalender
eingetragen 11 uhr mrt termin wegen
meinem knie also ich glaube jeder sieht
dass hier ein stück von der kniescheibe
einfach abgesplittert ist alles' zum
damals vom fußball so spielten die
fußball kinder auf jeden fall bin ich
gerade also zum arzt gefahren sagen so
hey ich hatte heute der termin und die
sony hatten heute die besprechung
bezüglich des mrt bildes sie müssen uns
das ist bei leben geben haben sie ja
natürlich mitgebracht und nicht so ich
dachte ich hätte heute dass er mit ihr
gehabt lange kurz das denn ich hatte
heute nicht mrt termin sondern die
besprechung die op besprechung wo ich
das mrt bild hätte mitbringen ist und
dass er mit hätte schon längst beim
radiologen machen müssen
also ich bin dumm und nach vergessenen
termin wann die logen zu machen aber ist
auch egal wo wir jetzt einer positiveren
sache und zwar hat mir
ps heute ein paket abgegeben und jetzt
fragt ihr euch vielleicht etwas ist er
da vielleicht fragt ihr euch auch nicht
aber falls ihr euch fragen sollte was da
drin sein könnte eventuell könnt ihr
euch noch an den block vor einiger zeit
erinnern in dem ich mir einen platz
besser bestellt habe mein gott freunde
ich hab so zeger das maus-team bekommen
es ist dieser orangen das wetter
[Gelächter]
erst angekommen was wir jetzt hier quasi
haben mit ist der slot wetter in diesem
lager baum steht eigentlich die gleiche
farbe wie mein porsche gerade das ist
traurig dass man auch video nicht
rüberbringen kann wie etwas riecht oder
wie sich etwas anfühlt weil dieser stoff
das ist sowieso eine ultra welches
rahmen tuch nicht voll von herles oder
irgendwie sowas aber vor
der schweizer fühlt sich schon besser an
das seminar keine zeit mehr dafür
deswegen mache ich mir jetzt erst mal
[Musik]
ich habe gerade sommer richtig fette
schale müsli gegessen und jetzt mein
bauch so richtig weg er sollte auf jeden
fall könnte ich mir jetzt glaube ich
erst mal ein mittagsschlaf und wirklich
in die sonne nach draußen
ich habe gerade einfach zweieinhalb
stunden draußen gepennt ich weiß nicht
ob man das hier gerade richtig erkennen
kann aber es scheint die sonne und es
regnet auch noch deutschland es ist
jetzt gerade ein bisschen zeit vergangen
ich hab grad noch relativ viel uni krems
gemacht so abschlusszeugnis und habe
schon ein paar kommentare für luca
kommentiert kommentare
habe ich schon ein paar kommentare
rausgesucht da ich allerdings noch bei
einem kumpel vorbeifahren wollte würde
ich sagen ja
er fährt vorbei du hast sicher mensch
jetzt die alleinige noch mal ein paar
mehr sehen vom 911 sehen wollten und den
motor sondern auch ein bisschen mehr
hören wollten haben wir hier nochmal
zwei aufnahmen für euch dann aufgenommen
am straßenrand
[Applaus]
[Musik]
einfach jeder bremst weil ich mit der
kamera darstellen und meint einfach
irgendeine polizisten blitzt
ich hoffe ihre spaghetti switches videos
eine zitrone
[Musik]
auch gegessen und irgendwie waren da
mehr oliven drin als alles andere damit
aufgegessen die von schon gesagt das war
ein echt hart viele oliven dadurch aber
nicht hasse oliven wie die pest tobias
stinkt übrigens hart nach scheiße wir
gehen jetzt wieder zu dem baby dem
porsche wie sind diese gerade im
parkhaus angekommen und 54 stand einfach
und schnell gerufen
das kann man auf jeden fall so machen
tschüss felge war sehr schön mit dir
schöne ist ja super wie fühlst du dich
super ich habe tobias krah zu hause
abgesetzt jetzt auf jeden fall auch hart
verknallt
ich weiß nach hause zu meinen eltern und
würde sagen dass uns dann dort
wiedersehen bei einer weiteren episode
von lukas kommentiert kommentare
50 auto 30 24 blog ja ja es stimmt
einfach warum bist du so dumm und längst
ich beim autofahren mit der kamera ab
dazu mal eine ganz kurze sache und zwar
ich weiß nicht ob die personen die hier
den kommentar geschrieben hat selber
schon mal ausgefahren ist aber ich finde
zum beispiel sehr viel gefährlicher wie
man bedienelemente gegen die ich hier
bedient also ihr müsst euch dass ihr so
vorstellen man sitzt so und fährt und
fordern schoppmann hin und wenn ich die
kamera gehabt habe was echt nicht bei
schnellen geschwindigkeiten der fall ist
dann wirklich wenn ich sehe okay hier
ist eine gefahrlose situation
ich fahr langsam alles cool also um auf
den punkt zu kommen
ich fahre so hat die kamera hier und da
ich die meiste zeit nach vorne gucken
habe ich vorne alles im blick und auch
wenn ich mir die kamera gucken konnte
habe ich das auch noch alles im blick
allerdings bin ich bei manchen anderen
autos einfach so dumm gehört wenn ich
habe zum beispiel keine kamera hätte
aber das navi bedienen möchte da muss
ich hierhin greifen zum beispiel bei bmw
oder bei mini da muss ich einfach in
diese mittelkonsole greifen und muss man
so irgendwie so gucken damit ich das
navi bedienen kann und das macht jeder
mensch deswegen finde ich es überhaupt
nicht schlimm dass ich da der kamera
also natürlich ist das kein gutes
vorbild aber ich finde diese chance
einfach cool so ihr seht dass sich auf
dem weg von einer location zu anderen
wenn das ist ein guter bürger also wenns
euch ab dann höre ich damit auf aber ich
finde es eigentlich ganz schön so als so
von wegen ich war grad hier und bin dann
kleiner tipp wenn ihr luca trifft pusht
niemals oder instagram her das verstehe
ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht so ganz
genau also ich habe letztens
beispielsweise der zuschauerin getroffen
die hofft beide videos anschaut die mir
die blogs und die meinte dann auch zu
mir hey nukleare folgen auf install aber
instagram name ist laser luca und ja es
kommt doch jetzt auch hier in den block
so rein bei minute 59 10 steht ein
fachbüro oder ja volt vielleicht noch
1000 leute jetzt unser video schreiben
das ich benutze die hallo mein name ist
luca dass ich so viel in meiner
begrüßung zurück gewünscht haben so
viele haben
sich danach gesehnt diese sagen und
wogenden forscher aus meinem mund zu
hören hallo mein name ist luca cool oder
ich bin ein bisschen nach überlegen da
ich jetzt halt wieder mehr zeit habe
wegen uni und soweit ich das jetzt
meinen bachelor habe dass ich das
vielleicht der nächste mache dass ich
wirklich alle zwei tage block machte
aber dazwischen dann halt immer noch
normale videos bleibt mir doch zu gerne
eure meinung unten in die kommentare
sind nicht wirklich mega interessieren
ich schreibe nutella rückwärts bevor es
alle tun
der recht in schneller frequenz ist
wirklich alle tot und übermorgen schule
ich habe einfach nie wieder schule
hey hast mich fröhlich luca du hast lass
ich vergessen verdammt stimmt aber es
gab neben mir klar wie findest du dass
du zu wenig in den blogs fokker ja
natürlich können zu teilweise öfter drin
vorkommen da gebe ich dir definitiv
frage das ist gemein an dieser stelle
würde ich luca kommentiert kommentare
jetzt allerdings auch beenden
es ist auch schon gerade halb eins nach
vielleicht sollte ich echt mal früher
ins bett gehen der nächste flop der in
zwei tagen auf einem kanal online gehen
wird wird auf jeden fall ein langes luca
reagiert mal wieder beinhalten und
danach bin ich auch wieder in köln und
da werde ich mit max sehr viele geile
sachen unternehmen also wir haben schon
mega die pläne aufgestellt es wird lädt
freunde
trotzdem würde ich an der stelle dem
blog hier jetzt beenden wenn euch
gefallen habe ich mich sehr über einen
live von euch freuen dass wir auf jeden
fall leicas tisch hier werden noch kein
abonnent von einem kanal seid könnt ihr
einfach unter dem video auch abonieren
klicken und verpasste keine videos mehr
wird offizieller teil der lupe und wenn
ihr schon ab und entscheiden könnt ihr
auf die glocke klicken
ich kann die kenne mich vor die tür
stellen jetzt hier für das auto werde
das waren meine schwester ist nebenan
und die ist ein bisschen krank und ich
möchte jetzt ehrlich gesagt nichts
aufwecken mit meiner lautstärke auf
jeden fall würde ich sagen dass die
im block ins weiter an wiedersehen
tschüs
[Musik]